projets en cours c'est qu'on va changer
de voiture alors qu'elle 84 1000 km ma
voiture
il ya des gens qui n'ont pas accès à des
véhicules propres donc mais qui doit
quand même aller travailler
l'a86 cette autoroute définit le
périmètre de la zone à faible émission
métropolitaine qui interdit depuis mardi
1er juin la circulation des véhicules
critères 4 une nouvelle phase
d'extension puisque les véhicules
critères cinq étaient déjà non autorisée
depuis 2019 c'est une décision
importante parce que c'est un processus
qui vise évidemment améliorer le cadre
de vie la santé puisque airparif estime
l'estimant verra en fera un bilan de
cette zone à faible émission à un moment
donné on peut baisser de 6 et 8 % les
émissions oxydes d azote est quasiment
équivalent sur les particules fines sur
la zone en question
normalement la zdf comprend deux commune
yvelinoise qui entrent dans le périmètre
intérieur de l'a86 viroflay et vélizy
villacoublay
ces deux mairies ne veulent pas de cette
interdiction pour ses usagers en 2d plus
une bonne partie avec les plus faibles
revenus et de le pont pour le plomb pour
simplement travailler on n'est pas allé
au bout il se rend compte que c'est une
bonne mesure il faut obtenir des
véhicules polluants un avis partagé par
l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes qui ne comprend pas
cette interdiction
vous avez des gens qui sont d'un côté à
80 du mauvais côté de la a86 qui ont
leurs bêtes salles d'aude côté qui ont
leur école de l'autre côté qui ont leur
commerce de l'autre côté ils pourront
plus aller chez leur médecin à l'école
ou à leur commerce
alors qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire on
prend leur voiture ils vont aller dans
la chambre commerciale à 20 ou 30 km à
l'extérieur
vous parlez d'une réduction de la
pollution donc tout ça a été mis en
place par des élites je pense que c'est
beaucoup plus politique que efficace en
termes de résultats pour autant des
aides seront mises en place pour changer
de véhicule jusqu'à dix neuf mille euros
pour un véhicule électrique ou hybride 9
et jusqu'à 12000 euros dette pour un
véhicule électrique ou hybride
d'occasions pour rappel les véhicules
avec vignette critères quatre sont des
voitures diesel immatriculés avant le
1er janvier 2006 les deux roues
motorisés d'avant juillet 2004 sont
également qu'on
armée